let me turn that up there we go
how's it going red that's my hand right
there very right there
welcome to gray it's it's made an sdk
which is pretty much half life 2
I guess it's free you don't need half
life to replace that's what's cool about
it and I'm looking forward to playing it
for a while so I'm glad glad I'm sitting
right here right now I'm glad we're
doing this press this will be a pretty
pretty epic cosplay and I hope you bros
will enjoy it with me so let's just cut
the crap and lets us do it a cold sweat
farming on my bra my unconscious mind
began farming in unfaith amah metaball
nightmare plunging down into deaths in
hell I fell I thought it was gonna say
hell I'm sorry I'm Swedish so you know
if I don't read good sorry
what you're not forgetting okay it's not
okay
what that's how I sleep I'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I [ __ ] this is how I wake up got it such
yep
that's just how we do it in this game
it's just 13 no it's a 19th thank God oh
hello
I like the black kid it's a tiny egg yet
okay and I have here this little thing I
guess this is my room
oh you are clearly not doing it right
don't disobey gravity ow all right
hideaway what there we go I like panic
mr. Joe night you got some nice red I'm
not gay okay just cuz I own it I wasn't
saying you were gay ah welcome to my
house these are my fish hooks and that
is my snake no snakes don't now man
these are my light bulbs that one has a
mustache I call her Jennifer
no Jared John Jeremy Jed John whatever
earth
hi that is nice
what a hell is going on in what that oh
[ __ ]
whoa no no no okay we're good what how
to help what does it say little well ah
[ __ ] I get so much good sponge for stuff
like this
okay we're fine alright just keep going
down here huh
don't follow me okay ha and I hide it
sorry shoe do pull I didn't do anything
but someone took him that's fine
okay Joe you're on your period you're
just a bet on period shut up not like
anyone what the hell is going on here
don't like this
shut up you like beatboxing that's cool
nice ah
holy [ __ ] that's a tight ass
okay that's nice but come on let me
throw it snakes back out
we're fine what I can click this car
that's cool
okay you okay yeah uh-huh
no [ __ ] I miss one yep
but I mess up the order yes
yeah hey
nice nice dance what do you call it then
capable mover that's nice nice keep
doing what you're doing you mess it up a
lot oh oh nice hey riddle I didn't you
know you were head Jeremy
oh man Rhonda God hey hey
okay let's go [ __ ] about sauna oh dude
ah my head was pounding my hands work
automatically
scrubbing themself again and again
slowly the Thunder somewhere in my head
began to recede the bar was quiet silent
even had they closed while I was been in
the bathroom I lost track of time I
needed to find where everyone had so
suddenly gun get back to normality [ __ ]
I hate when doors is [ __ ] open so
[ __ ] creepy this so far tonight when
it's creepy when it's creepy that's when
it might [ __ ] you that's when when you
go to bed and be like oh that's face
that [ __ ] face what is that a
character looks that's kind of gay I
hope that it not us
oh that's us Silent Hill right here
ladies and gentlemen you start off in
the bathroom
what it's crazy how so so many people
are inspired by Sandy Hook to so many
games interested in evil it's like what
started harder I guess it's crazy
I remember my let's play I couldn't get
out of the [ __ ] bathroom what what
what are ya doin here [ __ ] are you why
are you taking this jet oh I don't want
any that's all on it that it that
Qaddafi thank you okay okay look at that
guy hey there oh let's go to the lady
girl shut up come out here okay Eddie I
love how you you're sucks yeah that's
right I'm not gaping well what are you
doing
alright let's go out where the heavens
are everyone well this makes no sense at
all
why didn't I didn't want to know what're
is everyone I don't I don't like
close-up I think they did I think I
would explain a lot of things I like
this place it's nice I mean they have
boots in the wall well I guess that
means more like her than me no like they
had Mazar elastics I love this they're
delicious
okay let's give God yes that's how you
open doors by the way
magically open the door let's go to the
maintenance what's up mate dance what's
up everyone how you that danger it's not
going up n yes watch every time I like
it's my fans are you doing fans joking
me that's so ironic so so ironic huh
exit whoa plant I don't pay there's a
couple danger Shaban be careful alright
plaid take your advice I will take this
random syringe and my cones back door is
locked
[ __ ] me maybe the keys are in the office
I guess that would make sense where's
the office oh let the lid off King
colonic up couple down and pink upon all
the doula pot after pot a bit backward
before egg reporting kick okay over here
storage why does that office in a where
the heavens are the office where they
are there's the office
alright you just got to find it here are
you there cactus minutes mate okay ah
it's right there and see I mean can't
grasp it it's actually kind of children
animation but I don't know it looks kind
of funny
alright we got the key
let's cut to the excellence baby I was
just flying before alright again
I'd meet them no danger I feel like I
should go to the repair shop it might be
someone there it can help me I hate it
but I hate the repair shop tear service
tunnel under the house it's the shortest
way there let's take the shortest way
hello are you done
how's that run doing in a call
everything is fine [ __ ] you someone
jammed the lock I think I'll need to cut
it off you didn't have to find something
useful in the tool shop down the alley
you did not occur up
how convenient let me just open that and
Begay it's very passive all right here
we go why you're not picking up
take them off bro come on okay that's it
no what about this this gotta work why
don't you take pencil why I'm they're
having fake one tools heavy tools boss
sent me here to get some replacement
drill bits once think what are you doing
it now stop mouthing snake it's so lame
okay uh snapper what the hell
what this Oh
oh I found you there we go
the bug cutter excellent a bolt cutter I
think that was pretty good I'm not gonna
lie
did it all by myself didn't even need
you please can we just you sense that
would be so bad at all right let's go
back I think the voice actor is the same
one in cry fear I kind of recognize him
but it's a good bisector so why not you
know what I'm saying that's that's
that's totally the note on the floor
made me stop dead it seems so enjoy yes
but somehow I know it was meant for me
it had been plays here waiting for my
apparently inevitable Laura Hale the
letter gave me on one Claire an address
had blocked well still the Kurds at
handwriting's knee mountain and familiar
whose writing to me press any key to
continue
I clicked the mouse one key
[ __ ] we can't return but it says exit to
straight day but we can't go mr. cha
what did they do to you
I don't even know what no I don't like
this button what what it what in the
head and said whatever oh [ __ ]
but it says it's a gameboy oh it's a
game by batteries all right cut of what
I'm flashlight Oh No Hey okay it's
working at least that's pretty cool
there's a note over here yeah I can love
these these are the best
all right maybe in here ah [ __ ]
I know for me yep
I don't [ __ ] know storage do not pack
you hell yeah
first aid thank you
what clothes did I what is going on here
who flip that over was it you boxes I'm
looking at yeah well that's right I keep
my eye on you
okay I have no [ __ ] clue where we're
going but I exit huh nice of course but
what it's someone up there
Wow you don't mess with me [ __ ]
Oh hot hot
I can't stay late hey it's my fence
again
Joker me uh did you hear that one about
ketchup [ __ ] Oh what's going on why
does it say through blocked
what is it sight what does it fight
through block 12 what damn what in there
through block 12 I'm more surprised why
the hell did or else I [ __ ] up enough
to leave bloody no it's all over the
place it's [ __ ] up to open a door
without saying hey you're welcome or
something that times without you I wish
I had your haircut man all right I guess
we got to go back here maybe nope
get away from me get away from me that's
how I roll that's how I got the lead
[Music]
that time I roll the time I get only
that's how I roll
[Music]
Wow where's that said Jerry Springer
Derek Derek okay
like that don't even think about it
oh I thought I saw had it so you mad bro
what started oh my no I a what no matter
what a no matter I know I ain't even
touched in Robin sided pity powers here